how much money do you make I don't know
you gotta have an idea I have a money
guy when I first signed him 15 years ago
I got um
I don't want to know how much money I
have I don't want to live in a world
where I'm like always looking at my bank
account worried and this and that so um
yeah I don't know I don't know what I
pay for my mortgage I don't know what I
pay for my car I don't know what
insurance costs I don't know what my
lighting light utility costs all that's
taken care of every bill every bill
phone bill I don't even know where to go
to do it you curious no because the
number's really low I'll just be
depressed and I'll start panicking sure
like I need to do more but if you don't
know then you just kind of just I just
live my life like I asked my money guy I
go how long can I not work until I run
out of money yeah and he goes a long
long time